welcome to this video playing chromos
from Norway gotta Rui again they think
I've played played him a couple of times
in this opening I'm thinking place the
94 line the Yates variation if i'm not
mistaken yep he does that's in fact an
interesting alternative to the to the
main line with h h 3 can be recommended
it leads to it's too complicated
interesting play and is still avoiding
lots of theoretical um lines on our
knowledge that needs to be accumulated
in the main lines you can easily play
that without so much effort yeah what
I'm going for is trying to attack your
center with Bishop f6r played this
quickly maybe I'm confusing things yeah
but very often it is it is played in
that way we should f6 or am i running
into a ninja worm some e 5 business hmm
85 looks looks really strange yeah this
is here on on age 7 I cannot believe
that your five is good okay interesting
I've got 95 though isn't this isn't this
awkward
this looks very awkward for white it
does not really have a good square and
d3 i'm going night before and okay is
giving up the Queen
it's not enough compensation but the
other the other thing really looked at
Russia's moving the Queen again um so
let's see how to continue here I want to
I want to try to keep his count to play
to a minimum maybe maybe him first and
now I was thinking okay it's not
threatening to take on c5 I can go here
first attacking d5 yeah that's good
95 is Sam and now I wanted to go see
form to get get the C porn and sort of
trying to to blunt both bishops the for
bishop is now just on the board to
protect the pawn and b2 is looking at
the c-4 point okay make sure that I'm
not backing mated and rook c8 and B form
are the next the next moves okay so this
is probably good anyway
I don't want to fall behind now on time
in this in this position ok so a 5pm to
threaten before King g7 was not really
essential just making things a bit more
convenient ok perform I guess ok should
I take on mm I can also go a phone now
maybe a for putting putting more
pressure or c3 first at since it's good
that's good now getting the rook rook in
the invites camp to a to maybe or a one
yeah he's giving up the d5 pawn I'm not
sure that I'm that I should take it it's
probably nothing nothing wrong with
taking it but but still
okay maybe he's got Bishop before so I
can just go back
it's not not threatening much how do i
get the pawns going there don't see it
at the moment maybe rugae one still okay
there's bishop age 60 not good okay
ruki eight this is a problem hmm ok I
rather exchange look Sam ok well now i
can take general c8
can I go see to now get get this forward
yeah come on with Roxy 3 coming or Pepsi
393 whatever
time warning
the time again why did I come into to
some time some trouble again
t5
I really did lose some control over this
game it was a check much much clearer
winnett at some other time no I'm I'm
fine again but I heard like it should
have been much clearer light resigns
somehow it got got out of hand a bit at
least it felt like I should have had
something better yeah hehe just drained
into this very inconvenient position he
can play if I of him I had the suspicion
now the computer gives it as very good
for what does this Queenie for idea is
really a problem despite the Queen being
on the same file here e 2 against the
rook it seems to be good yeah this is
the point yeah I was some are hoping
that I have some have something against
you five but it seems that I must must
go here this is not really great yeah
this is just very awful and instead he
played this after which i'm i am better
yeah maybe you should try to move the
Queen still i mean this is this is
probably losing see takes it seems it's
the best because of Queen B 6 I see but
okay I kept I kept full controller
weather over the position so nothing
nothing bad happened
but then right here yeah I know the
computer is on plus six but still I
wasn't so sure how to win this yet it
keeps the plus 6 all the way Knight b6
now but this is also plus 6 minus 11
well yeah so okay I was I was too
pessimistic here after all I'm a huge
material check but it's so felt the
experience of the last couple of
sessions really made me made me cautious
iam okay well thanks for watching